foreign
in this portion of our world views and
values class we're now going to look
at the thought of a 20th century
american social theorist theologian
and activist martin luther king jr
and we're going to look at two works in
particular these are both short works
one is the letter from a birmingham jail
and the other is the i have a dream
speech these are probably some of the
most
famous writings of king who wrote a
number of other things including several
books
and the reason why we're going to focus
on those in particular
is because they're very accessible and
they contain a lot of the key themes of
his thought in in a very
concise consolidated form
they also deal with some of the key
themes that we're used to looking at in
this class having to do with the nature
of the human person
the nature of society and the underlying
reality
in which both of those are grounded so
as usual we're going to look at the
literary genre of these works first and
then we're going to talk about the
historical context
in which they're they're written and
actually for one of them spoken
and then we'll talk about some of the
main themes that you should
you could keep your eye out for as
you're reading through this
when we turn to look at the literary
genre of these works they're really
given away
in the very titles the letter from a
birmingham jail the
i have a dream speech so that's the two
genres that these fall into and
those bring up some some important
points
both the letter and the speech are
designed to be read
in different circumstances and to work
in different ways
than say a you know dense philosophical
treaties like a discourse would be
um they're not they're not exactly
dialogues either although they have a
sort of imaginary dialogue going
on with them with the reader with the
hearer they are
very dramatic and the speech
particularly is is rhetorically crafted
so you're going to see a lot of
what we call rhetorical techniques built
into it there's also some some really
high powered thinking going on in those
and so you have a sort of fusion of
composition
and let's just call it philosophy
going on there philosophy that's focused
on social matters
now one of the things that i want to
point out in talking about these
is that when we talk about rhetoric
one of the key elements of rhetoric is
thinking about audience and
martin luther king is actually telling
you in the letter
who his original primary audience is
uh and these are not you know just
everybody in general but clergymen
who are disagreeing with his his tactics
with the things that he's doing
with the very fact that he's been thrown
in jail he's writing this
from jail that's why it's letter from a
birmingham jail
he didn't write it the way that we do on
you know say a legal pad
he wrote it on the margins of newspapers
and had had it smuggled
out and then you know composed later
and reprinted but he's writing to these
clergymen
it's not however
confined just to them this is what you
call an open letter
an open letter is one where you're
writing to
one person or one group of people or
perhaps a corporation
but you also have a whole bunch of other
people in mind
that you want to read this and react to
it and respond to it
so who are the people that the king is
writing to
it includes other people in the civil
rights movement
but it also includes people in
in the white and in the african-american
communities particularly in the south
who were opposed to the civil rights
movement
and some of them are you know hardcore
segregationists among among the whites
some of them are the so-called white
moderates who he talks about being very
disappointed with
and some of them are african-americans
who've been so
beaten down that they've they've sort of
lost
the sense that they could in fact stand
up and demand civil rights and some of
them
are those who are advocating violent
uh resistance to the the segregation
regime
so he has all of those people in mind
with the letter from a birmingham jail
and he names all of them
in that work i think you can also see
that i have a dream speech
as doing the same thing but you know
that one it's good to keep in mind that
this is a speech that
king is giving in front of a crowd
of a quarter of a million people in the
nation's
capital with the eyes of the nation and
the world upon him
so he's speaking for um you know the the
civil rights movement
its aspirations but he's speaking to
people who may not be
already convinced about that and trying
to win them over
now the way that he wins them over is
not just by saying you know some some
cool things that they might be able to
get behind or appealing to
emotions it's to provide
an articulation of an intellectual
analysis
and argument in both cases with some
very
deep ideas um
what we see going on in this is
he's dealing with some some crises of
the moment as a matter of fact these are
both
from 1963 so they're relatively short
uh time frame but um
he's dealing with perennial
philosophical themes he's he's framing
these
in terms of the bigger picture which is
why we're looking at these in terms of
world views and
values um he's outlining some of the key
themes of his analysis of racism of
inequality of non-violent action
and of the goals of the the movement
itself
now one of the things that i do want to
point out as far as genre goes
about these pieces the the uh
letter from a birmingham jail is very
often anthologized
in college textbooks and when i was in
high school it was something that we
actually read
and you know went over i was very
surprised to find out
as i was teaching the current crop of
students that very few of them had
actually read
the letter from the birmingham jail
because apparently it's not part of the
high school curriculum anymore
and i think that both of these these
documents the letter from a birmingham
jail
and the i have a dream speech are
especially important for us to read
in part because so many people make
reference to them
and usually they refer to one or two
lines from them
but they don't actually read them and if
you don't read these
texts you're depriving yourself of the
experience of confronting
thought that's emerging from a
context of incredible struggle
for civil rights that are very
articulately
very very well thought out
and so it's important to actually
read through these carefully not to
approach them as if we
already know exactly what they're saying
civil rights good segregation bad
but to look at the arguments to look at
what's being said
to look at the ideals that are being
articulated in these
let's talk now about the historical
context for these two documents
and if you had to say it in just one
sentence
the historical context for these two
documents is that they are
parts of a struggle
against racism against a particular kind
of inequality
in both the american south and america
uh you know writ large in the 1960s
now the civil rights struggle had been
going on for quite some time
king's involvement in it begins really
in
in the 1950s and continues through
into the 1960s all the way up until 1968
when he's going to be assassinated
after you know giving one of one of his
other major speeches the i
uh have been to the mountain uh the
mountaintop
um let's talk a bit about the historical
context
of um the civil rights struggle because
it's something that i think
a lot of people because it's so close in
time
and because it's been so publicized a
lot of people think that they know an
awful lot about it but um they have sort
of just you know
a few pictures or flash points in their
head so
what was going on the civil rights
struggle had been going on
for a long time we could say that it
actually began before the civil war
in part through the abolitionist
movement um that it was carried out both
by
by whites and by by african-americans
you know frederick douglass would be a
prime example of that
writing in the north and
once the civil war occurs and
emancipation takes place
in the american south there is
a regime that's supposed to equalize
things called reconstruction
where the north you know has military
troops in the south to try to enforce
um say you know voting uh allowing
african americans to actually vote or
enforce property um you know and and uh
other regulations that were supposed to
equalize things
um it didn't last for very long and
you know there was already what we would
nowadays call domestic terrorism going
on
you know with the ku klux klan in the
south
and and other movements as well and what
happens in the south
is once the union troops are gone
um there's a resurgence of
of a racism that had never disappeared
and when we talk about racism we should
actually pause for a moment
and think about what racism means in
this context
so racism can be understood in terms of
two different things that come together
there's other ways of understanding it
that we'll talk about later
one of these is the idea that there are
indeed
human races and this was coming out
of the the thinking and even the science
of the 18th and 19th century and it
continued well into the 20th century
um you know in in if we look at modern
day genetics
you can say that the the idea of race as
it's been played out in america
or even in other places is really kind
of a fiction but a fiction that has had
some extremely
deep roots and an extremely um you know
wide impact upon the human race because
we're all genetically
compatible with each other we're all
part of one race or one species
and as it turns out ethnicity is
something very very different
genetic ethnicity is very different than
what we thought it was so for example
you know if we talk about a black race
and we're talking about sub-saharan
africa
there's actually a lot of different
genetic populations in there
that can be quite different from each
other and the same thing goes for
white or you know red or yellow or
whatever you want to say
these these populations don't break down
so
neatly but a lot of the thinking of the
time categorized the world
into essentially colors
i suppose because colors were an easy
way to categorize
uh people you know according to
continents
of course you know when it came to the
consideration of what counted as
white it took a lot of time for the
groups of people that we now consider
automatically white like say the irish
to actually be considered white in the
united states but
um we've got this notion there of race
as races being distinct from each other
as
being things that you can say have a
kind of identity
or an existence apart from the the
individuals
on the other hand combining with that is
a notion about a kind of
hierarchization of races
inequalities between them and
inequalities
in terms of their their propensities
or their capabilities and even more
important
inequalities in terms of economics in
terms of who is free and who is not free
inequalities in terms of legal
protection
inequalities on a social scale
inequalities in terms of education
and you put those two together and you
get racism
uh and along with you know that is is
coming this notion that well the races
you know for example shouldn't mix or
one race should be dominant over another
race
and this had such a strong hold over the
south but also over large parts of the
north as well as as blacks
made their way into the northern cities
and in some of these great migrations
they encountered incredible uh prejudice
and
and racism were you know pushed into
ghettos where they were
effectively constrained there by the way
in which the legal system worked the way
in which
property worked the way in which the
economic system worked
um what was going on in the south was
was
quite overt in many respects
um and it was a regime that was
you know carried out by brute force
in many cases not just social policy
or you know people controlling the
economics but
actual you know what we nowadays call
call terrorism
you know the lynchings that took place
in the south were effectively domestic
terrorism
terrorism is the use of violence to try
to
you know attain political ends uh
generally to
to keep some group of people down
uh by scaring the hell out of them
that's why it's called terrorism
so this has been going on in the south
for a long time and there were there
were you know times and places
where african americans were able to to
rise
able to build institutions i actually
had the fortune to teach at one of those
institutions in one of my previous
positions fayetteville state university
north carolina
second oldest university in north
carolina it was founded by these these
seven men
all african-americans who decided to
create a school
for african americans primarily as a
teacher's college
and it continued on and now it's part of
the university of north carolina system
it's known as a historically black
college or university
hbcu and there were a lot of
institutions like this there you know
there were
there was the rise of a a black middle
class as it was called
both in the south and in in the north
you know the midwest
and in harlem and in places like that
but they were always subject to to you
know
being taken down and to having their
property destroyed or confiscated
by whites who would be then protected by
the legal system
not prosecuted and so their existence
was always
rather precarious now that was supposed
to change
in terms of civil rights
and the naacp
had fought for a long time the legal
battles that are really
a you know precursor to the civil rights
struggle
so we see important you know cases like
brown versus
uh board of education or plessy versus
ferguson
which are saying that you know the the
regime
of segregation of you know maintaining
these strict separations of
of whites and african americans in the
south were actually against the american
constitution
they were detrimental to american
society they were detrimental to the
people who were being
affected by them especially those upon
whom the brunt of that
fell but the problem was
these these requirements to desegregate
to
integrate african americans and whites
within the same society
were not being followed there there's a
lot of heel dragging there was a lot of
well you know we'd love to do that but
we don't have the money
and we're spending the money over here
on something else
and there was a lot of you know two
steps forward one step
back going on and so that is part of
what gave rise to the civil rights
struggle
um you'll remember that one of the
defining moments of that in the 1950s
is the bus boycott which is you know
sparked originally by rosa parks
saying i'm not going to give up my my
spot on the bus
to some white guy who's telling me to
you know to get out of my seat
that was part of the custom of the time
whites were being
given a good treatment blacks were being
given as bad of a treatment as possible
and this is a matter of course and so
african americans
stood up against this and said we we've
had enough and they were taking a lot of
risks by doing that
now one of the other things that that's
important to think about in the context
here
that king actually mentions in the
letter from a birmingham jail
is that we see in the 1950s and the
1960s
all sorts of movements happening
overseas
that are aimed at attaining equality
and attaining justice and attaining
freedom for the at that time you know
colonized and oppressed peoples
of asia africa the caribbean
south america all over the place so you
know white racism
you know putting the the sort of um
white europeans at the top of the
pyramid and having them
be the ruling class sometimes even just
restricting it to you know white
anglo-saxon protestant
if they could they could pull that off
that was breaking down
all over the world colonialism was in
retreat
um people were attaining freedom uh
the the capacity to decide for
themselves
it was becoming clear that the the old
justifications for this sort of regime
were breaking down the so-called white
man's burden
uh didn't turn out to be really a burden
for the whites but rather for everybody
else
in in these areas and so you know people
like martin luther king and all the
other people in this this non-violent uh
resistance movement
and even in other movements were saying
why is that happening over there but not
here in america
this is supposed to be the most
prosperous country on earth
this is supposed to be a place that
cares about freedom it's in the
declaration that
you know all men are created equal that
they have these unalienable rights
why isn't this sort of thing happening
here when it can happen
over there when you know they can kick
the the power structure out
in these new african republics when you
know
france is getting out of these these
colonies that they have and they've been
administering
um because they're being booted out you
know by people by people fighting
against them
so this is a very powerful um question
to ask
and it's a very timely one uh in the
1960s when these two documents are
coming about uh martin luther king it's
worth thinking about his own biography
as we read through these king was
a a person who grew up in the south and
experienced the the brunt of racism
saw all these things happening first
hand
he had a father who was uh unwilling
to go along with with some of these
things and who
who protested from time to time against
them
um father was also you know quite a
disciplinarian when it came to martin
luther king jr himself
and um he he ended up
sort of living through and reconsidering
and
changing his his views on some of these
things at one time he would not have
considered himself
somebody who would be you know
ultimately a christian minister a
baptist minister
but he had to go through a lot of soul
searching a lot of experiences
and eventually settle down on on
something as being you know
the right thing for him the right thing
for his people the right thing for
the movement similarly with non-violence
king was not
originally although we think of him as
like you know
the guy for non-violence he he was
originally for what was called
armed self-defense but you know over
time he
he uh was was influenced by it by other
people then started you know looking at
what gandhi had done with non-violent
resistance
in africa and there's this entire chain
of
thought that goes you know from king
back to gandhi
from gandhi back to tolstoy and where is
tolstoy getting his ideas from
from the sermon on the mountain from
from this guy jesus christ
who you know they're all being
influenced by so king
is over time allowing these these ideas
allowing these possibilities
to work upon him and then taking them
and
creatively incorporating them as part of
his
his response and saying hey you you
other people you can do this
and we can all do this together as a way
to to fight against
what's going on so
if we want to get more specific about it
these two documents
are coming out of a context in which
king along with some other religious
leaders
had formed back in 1957 the southern
christian leadership
conference which was organized in part
to fight against racism to fight against
segregation
to try to attain civil rights for for
all americans particularly for the
exploited
and and oppressed african americans in
the south
and they'd engaged in a lot of different
protests you know by the time that king
is
is arrested and goes to jail in
birmingham
it's not his first time as a matter of
fact i think it was his 13th or so
time being arrested as a demonstrator as
somebody who's trying to
work for civil rights these two
works as i mentioned are coming out of
one year
1963 and in 1963
there is early on this um this struggle
that the the southern leadership
the southern christian leadership
conference had gotten involved in
in the city of birmingham um you know
blacks were still not being granted
their civil rights not being allowed
to vote you know not being allowed to do
a whole bunch of things
the laws of the city of birmingham were
set up in such
a predatorial manner as to try to
exclude
african americans from every aspect of
life
what he actually went to jail for was a
law that that
didn't allow you to have demonstrations
or marches without a permit
and of course they weren't granted a
permit for the demonstration that they
were doing so they they got sent to jail
so king is writing from a context in
which he's
you might say in the dungeon in the
citadel
of the the enemy and he's
arguing for the need not to treat
the oppressor as an enemy
but actually to witness to dramatize
some higher calling and he's writing to
fellow ministers who were condemning him
and the the other protesters
for engaging in law breaking so he's
going into a very
important exposition about the nature of
law
itself the the other document the eye of
a dream speech
is coming from the the march on
washington for jobs and freedom which
eventually drew
a quarter of a million people into the
capital
you know to hear all these these
speeches and king's speech
is one of the center pieces of that that
march
in it what he's doing is he's
articulating in a very powerful form
the um not only what they're struggling
against but what they're struggling for
and how they're struggling
for it so this is all part of
the um the literary the historical
context in which you should be
reading these two pieces
what are the main themes that you should
particularly
pay attention to and try to frame things
in terms of as you're reading through
these these two documents
well one of them is of course racism
the experience of what racism is
like which he talks about quite a bit
what it does
to the human personality both of the
oppressed and of the oppressor
and why racism is fundamentally
wrong racism understood as a
irrational and arbitrary form of
inequality
another key idea that king talks about
is what you can call a network of
mutuality
his idea being that injustice being
practiced
anywhere affects everybody in one way or
another
directly or indirectly and that
correlatively
those who become aware of injustice
happening in another place
have a duty to do what they can to try
to bring
justice where there is injustice
another key theme that you're going to
see worked out in these
is non-violent resistance or non-violent
action
as a response to racism as a response to
injustice taking place
and king is going to talk quite a bit
about what the conditions for this
happen to be one of those furnishes us
with another
key theme which is that what he's trying
to do
is to dramatize the conditions that
means to produce
something like a a human play
in which you can see who the the good
guys are
and who the bad guys are and you can
tell who the bad guys are
even though you weren't sure about that
before because they're the ones using
force
aggression fraud and fear as their
tactics against those who are standing
up for
justice another interesting idea that he
brings out
is what he calls creative tension this
this idea
of making things even tenser in a
situation
but doing so in a creative way rather
than in a destructive way
a way that is is leading ultimately
towards
liberation another key
theme that you should pay particular
attention to
is his discussion about just and unjust
laws what is it in a legal system or a
system that's trying to impose
order that actually calls forth
our obedience our responsibility
it's it's not every single law it's not
every single authority that we should be
paying attention to as a matter of fact
according to king
we should be critiquing and reacting to
and trying to undermine some of them
those that are just we should we should
obey
those that are unjust we we shouldn't
along with this goes king's conception
of
personality as something that is
inherently
valuable as something that can be
damaged even degraded and destroyed
or also can be promoted and uplifted
this is part of how he makes sense out
of the moral law
that governs just an unjust laws
another key idea is the
very meaning of time is time
something that we can count on to
eventually bring about progress or does
it take human beings
deliberately taking risks deliberately
putting themselves in harm's way
deliberately standing up to injustice
and oppression
in order for progress to be made that's
a key question
that's being asked there
along with that goes this conception of
the
power of love to transform things
king is an advocate of love
as opposed to bitterness as opposed to
violence as opposed to
you know playing tit for tat and
engaging in reprisals
one of the other things that he talks
about quite a bit is what he calls
racial justice which is the ultimate
goal
okay condition of harmony and
integration between the races in which
persons would be in fact respected as
persons
in which as he calls it in the i have a
dream speech
a condition in which his children or any
of us
would be judged by the content of our
character rather than the color of our
skin
or any other arbitrary measure like the
uh
you know the number of zero signs
in our our our uh checking account or
you know anything else along those lines
content of character is what really
matters
he also talks about the american dream
and the promise that is made in terms
of the american dream he talks in the i
have a dream speech about
um the the you know the united states
when it
made its constitution and and
declaration of independence
as having issued a check which has been
bounced
several times so far but eventually is
going to be paid out
finally um one of the the last things
that i want to bring your attention to
is king's critique of what we can call
a false position of moderation
the the moderates that he's appealing to
saying you're sitting on the fence
saying slow things down
you know i know that segregation is not
a good thing and you guys have been
oppressed
but this isn't really the way to go
about it king is saying
that those people actually need to make
a choice
which way they're going to go so those
are
some of the key thing key themes to keep
in mind
as we go through these these two works
i think that gives you a good solid
foundation
for tackling these two that like i've
pointed out a lot of people
you know talk an awful lot about but
you're actually going to be reading